can like guess it uh maybe the other
thing I guess for men's issues um when
when I was younger I was like 22 so like
five years ago maybe uh my brother tried
to commit suicide okay and so it kind of
It kind of made me like understand and
it was it was over like a breakup like
that sort of thing and so it made me um
realize that if men don't get the
correct information it could kind of
mess up and were you were you close with
your brother oh I'm really close with
him he's um yeah he's like one of the my
brothers are like the best people I know
like seriously I I couldn't survive
without him I think probably that might
have had the bigger impact you know yeah
probably he um yeah cuz he's my little
brother so he's like two years younger
than me and he's just see that sounds
like a real yeah he's um reason to yeah
and he he's good now we'll kind of joke
about it now he's like I can't believe I
did that over a mid we kind of joke but
um yeah he's yeah I I have five brothers
so it's like a big family MH so
yeah no it's and doing this stuff kind
of made me understand because I didn't
understand why he did that I was like
what is wrong with you like over a chick
like what is you know and then it was it
kind of made me understand it like more
what he went through did you want to
save not save but you did you want to
help men like your brother is that maybe
one of the reasons I get started because
you realize that he was in a certain
fragile state and you and you wanted
other men who were in that same position
not to go through what he went through
yeah no seriously cuz I don't know it
was that was really hard to like watch
to be honest but like he's like better
now so I don't try to make it like a big
thing but you know back then yeah no no
no it's good that you told me that CU I
always try to understand where
everyone's coming from like everyone's
got motivation it's it's better to like
for me to understand where you're coming
from like throughout this conversation
and Beyond and for the public to
understand I think this stuff is
important because people will make if
you don't give them something they'll
make the Assumption you know what I mean
like my trauma or something yeah yeah
but any a way that was traumatic for you
wasn't it um yeah but I was more
actually I was more mad than I was like
I guess say I was like what is what the
hell like why would you do that you know
but um that was a Calamity for you yeah
I don't know what that means but it was
it was a big tragic event yeah yeah it
put you through emotional turmoil yeah
yeah I guess at the time so no no no for
sure I understand so I I think um we you
mentioned Islam and you said I don't
know if I'm be a Muslim or not um you
are you a Christian or what's I'm a
Catholic okay so but I I'm not a real
Catholic I think because every time I
say I'm Catholic everybody says I'm not
real so I guess I'm a fake
Catholic I don't know I do have
questions about the Mary stuff I do have
questions about it I would say I still
so I was trying to figure out what
religion I was a couple years ago I was
like 22 M and I I put all of the
religions like down now I'm not saying
this is the best way to come to a
conclusion so don't don't say this like
you should try that this is just how I
thought at the time I felt like
the I had to pick between Christian
Catholic or Jewish Islam I just I felt
like was too different you know I just
was like I couldn't see myself you know
and it seemed like at the time there was
a lot of like Muslim like prop I would
say it's probably propaganda and
hindsight so I thought maybe like it
seems like people are leaving those
countries so maybe like if I was God I
would make countries that followed God
like do better that's that's how I
thought then I had learned about Jewish
people and honestly the things that you
had to do to join that religion I was
like I just don't want it that bad I
don't and then I was Christian or
Catholic and I picked Catholic because I
noticed how woke all the Christians were
and I felt like with no structure like
the idea of people reading the Bible and
coming to their own
conclusions it sounds nice but I'd seen
it in practice and like I'd been in a
church that was Christian and it was
like they they were pushing the BLM
stuff you know and I was like what is up
with all these Christian churches
hanging gay flags and I attributed that
to them reading the Bible and deciding
for themselves does that make sense so
Catholics seem to make the most sense to
me the one thing and this is why I say I
guess I'm not a real Catholic because I
ask questions
um it confuses me or I noticed a pattern
where people tend to elevate women above
where they are so like we kneel to women
in proposals and they used to do that
with um King they used to kneel to Kings
and the women came in and said give
kneel to me and then all the guys did it
simps and um I wonder sometimes if
Catholics did the same thing with Mary
of course I don't know I don't know and
that's why I don't mother I'm not a
scholar so don't please all the
Catholics get so mad at me Catholics
still makes more sense to me than the
Christians because I go to the Christian
churches and there's all this woke stuff
I mean I went to one and they're like
he's like on the floor like shouting I'm
like what are you no offense blessing
it's just that's weird to me I'm like
what are you what are you doing you know
so I like the like structure of the
Catholic mass I like that it's been like
the same overtime I question the Mary
stuff a little bit but I wouldn't say
I'm like a super Rel you know overly
religious Mak sense I think look
religion is a way that you consider
yourself when you die right you're going
to have some kind of a log that you hold
on
to uh when you die right so religion is
like the log that you hold on to in a
sea or an ocean after you die and you
want the right one to keep you afloat
okay it you're you're not looking when
you're looking at religion you shouldn't
be looking at that which is going to
serve your interests it's like religion
is not a butler like is here to help you
and serve you uh in that way when
someone is looking for religion
effectively what they're trying to do is
look for truth mhm um and sometimes the
truth can be something which people
don't like um and so the first thing I
would not just for you but for anybody
he's looking for
truth it doesn't matter how different or
similar that truth looks or how weird or
strange or it may appear if the truth is
coming from a particular direction and
it is the truth then one if one is
sincere then they'll follow the truth
now Islam look I if you look at
Catholicism is Christianity obviously
Christianity is broken into different
sects and Catholicism and protestantism
are the two major sect the third one
being um Orthodox Christianity to say um
Orthodox like the only other one I think
really hasn't gone off the rails it's
probably more so than Catholicism by the
way oh yeah I would agree they're
they're like a little bit more strict I
guess um well I mean once again uh this
is my observation as a Muslim I think
that Orthodox Christians whether they're
orientalist Oriental Orthodox like in in
Egypt where I'm originally from they
have Oriental Orthodox Church whether
they're Greek Orthodox or whether
they're Russian Orthodox or whatever
kind of Orthodox Ethiopian Orthodox all
the above they focus heavily on the um
basically how the church fathers done
things and how so Traditions a big part
of their religion more so I would say
than Catholicism although Catholicism
does uh obviously believe in that as
well and well we changed a bunch of
stuff and I found out the other day we
changed a bunch of stuff in the 70s yeah
oh I figured you would you're the you
seem like the scholar so I was like you
you probably know more than me in the
70s I mean I don't know exactly what
you're talking about Catholicism yeah
they changed they used to not let women
be alter servers Chang that they changed
I guess it used to always be um Latin
mass and I guess they switched that um I
think that was way before but I mean the
thing is there's few things like one of
the major ones is the theory of
evolution that's I you've had you've had
different uh opinions on that obviously
what the Pope says is from God uh in
Catholicism but obviously he has to say
it in his magisterium he can't just say
it walking around so that's one thing
you'll find that many things that
Catholics believed in the past they
don't no longer believe for example
there was a big controversy in the 4th
Century with Augustine because uh he was
he believed that a child that hadn't
been baptized a baby that hadn't been
baptized would go to hell and this was
the Catholic belief up until quite
recently and then they changed that as
well so there is good evidence of a
change in verdicts and pronouncements
and stuff like that and Catholic faith
but more so I would say with the whole
of Christianity the main thing that's
been changed is the Bible itself you
know oh yeah yeah so this is what we
would say because you were saying you
mentioned something key which is that
you like things staying the same all
right something a proof of something
being true is that it stayed the same
yeah now if you look at the beliefs of
the Christians from the first century to
the third Century the fourth Century
that hasn't sted the same there's a
clear development in the christology in
the Theology of the Christian people so
I have a question would the Christian
because this is what happens to me
sometimes people will come on my show
and they'll say things yeah and and then
no no no no no but I'm saying like then
now obviously I I would you say you're
religious scholar or like you at least
debate it a lot no I'm a comparative
religionist um so I do comparative
religion okay yeah I I could just State
the position of Islam if that makes
better sense for you guys instead of
speaking about Christianity no no no you
can that's not what I was going to say I
was going to say what would if I asked a
Christian like scholar person would they
agree with you on that of course not a
Christian would say that this the
Trinity has always been the idea of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit has
always been what Christians have
believed in from the beginning or even
what Abraham believed in what the Jews
believed in don't forget I mean the the
Bible is comprised of the Old Testament
and the New Testament yeah so the Old
Testament you have characters like
Abraham Noah Moses Etc they came before
Jesus mhm and so the question is what
did they believe did they believe in
three and one and one and three a
Christian may say Yes actually they did
believe in that even though they didn't
spell it out in any elaborative detail
in the Old Testament they'll say yes
they did believe that we would say
where's the evidence for this that's
that's how the conversation would go
where's the evidence for this they will
say there's they'll bring some kind of
evidence but there's nothing in the Old
Testament
that would indicate the Hebrew Bible for
example that's what the Jews call it
that would indicate three co-eternal
co-equal persons and if it if it was so
clear then why are the Jews not
believing that because remember the
Hebrew Bible is something that the Jews
and the Christians both believe in
there's not one sect of Judaism that
believes in the Trinity and they had the
most access to this book for hundreds of
for thousands of years and so where
Muslims and Jews would agree is on the
idea of God that it's only one God mhm
and you ask yourself what makes more
sense uh do you believe in one God that
is the creator of the heavens and the
Earth or do you believe that Jesus
himself is God that he is unlimited he's
all powerful all that kind of thing
which one makes more sense to you so I
have a question would do you guys
believe that Jesus was crazy then
because then wouldn't that oh oh you're
nodding so yeah no no we would no cuz
wouldn't cuz he would be crazy then if
he cuz he was going around saying he was
God so that's the thing we would we
wouldn't agree that he was going around
saying that he was God mhm that where we
differ with the Jews and agree with the
Christians okay so we we agree with the
Jews Muslims agree with the Jews in so
much as we say that there's only one God
worthy of worship and that's the creator
of the heavens and the Earth it's not a
man it's not a woman it's not a holy
ghost it is the creator of the heavens
and the Earth and that God is all
powerful all knowledgeable etc etc where
we would agree with the Christians and
disagree with the Jews is that actually
there was This Man Called Jesus Christ
who we consider to be a prophet
as the book of Acts mentions it says
that he's a man amongst men that was
sent with wonders and miracles and signs
that God did through him so we believe
that God chose Jesus in his time to
deliver the message that there's only
one God worthy of
worship we don't believe that he ever
said that I am God or worship me uh even
if you look at the New Testament you
won't find him really elaborating upon
this in fact there are verses to the
opposite of this M for example in the
Book of John chapter
17:3 it's says that there's only one
true God which is the father and that
you Jesus was sent to him I by the
Finger of God cast out Devils I by the
uh I by the spirit of God such and such
I by my own self can do nothing Jesus is
saying this himself I by my own self can
do nothing it's a verse in the Bible in
New Testament so what we're saying is
that there isn't it doesn't indicate
that Jesus himself was going around and
saying he was God we believe that
historically what we can find about
Jesus is that really he was a prophet he
was a messiah he did Miracles and all
this kind of thing but he wasn't God
that was um a Roman invention that was
put in place that's the idea so we
wouldn't call him a liar so you think
the in Rome they invented that he was
God so in the beginning what happened is
that Christianity was A persecuted
religion in Rome right so the Roman
Empire is where Christianity was was MH
and in the beginning they were
persecuted minority they were being
persecuted by all kinds of people right
up until the Third or the fourth Century
you had this guy called Constantine okay
he was the emperor at the time he had a
dream okay he had a dream with a cross
and all that kind of thing and he became
a Christian okay even though
Christianity had been a minority
religion and they were a persecute
persecuted minority for a very long time
and when he became a
Christian um in in 313 there was
something called the Edict of malan and
then 325 there something called the Nan
Creed they started to formulate what is
the belief of the Christians 325 they
said it was you know you have the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit this idea of
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
came out oh and then you guys you guys
had the same text and it didn't change
right we believe I think I've heard sneo
say that right yeah so the Quran look so
to finish the story on this right we
believe that Christianity had been
interpolated had been people have come
in m and change the original beliefs of
Jesus so for example you had a group
called The ebionites and you can Google
them and if it's open uh you know
historical information okay the
ebionites were a first century Christian
group who did not believe that Jesus was
God but they believed that he was the
Messiah so they had very similar much
more similar beliefs to Muslims than
Christians do
today um Christians believe the father
is equal to the the son is equal to the
holy spirit all three persons are God
but there's not three Gods but one God
we would say that's a contradiction you
see how can you have three and one at
the same time it doesn't make sense so
what happened is um Islam is a
continuation from Christianity from from
Jesus Christ We Believe Muhammad who's
the we believe the final prophet he was
sent in Arabia and he went when he was
40 to the cave and the angel had an
interaction with him and he had revealed
the Quran to him the Quran we believe is
the verbatim speech of God and in that
verbatim speech of God you know there
are prohibitions there are allowances
what to do what not to do etc etc etc we
also believe that this text and there
good evidence to show that has been
preserved for the whole time nothing has
been changed of it unlike the Bible and
if I asked if I asked the Christians
would they agree with that that the
Quran hasn't been changed or would they
say because often what I find is both
groups say the other is lying yeah very
much well it depends on what Christian
you ask if you if you ask a fair-minded
Christian who's a scholar and academic
they may say yes we agree with the
Muslim notion that the Quran has not
been uh changed but if you ask a pmic or
an apologist for Christianity he'll say
no the Quran has been changed just like
the Bible but they wouldn't deny that
the Bible has been changed so there are
for example great Scholars of
Christianity like Bruce mear who's come
out and wrote a book about how the Bible
has been
changed um so that's one thing the other
thing is so we've got the idea of God
and you've got ask yourself an honest
question which one makes more sense let
me ask you in fact which one makes more
sense the idea of three persons quot
equal quot Eternal all the idea of one
God if we're being honest about this one
God or three persons well I guess the
way they taught it to me was that it's
like
um it they're going to roast me because
I know I'm not going to explain it right
but but it's like um it's like three in
one so it's it's still one God but it's
just like there there's it's like three
in one yeah I know but you got the
father you got the son and you got
Spirit the father is God the son is God
the holy spirit is God but how many gods
are there one would take one but but
does that make sense to you kind of kind
of so if I had a fourth and say no and
also the disciples for example when when
do I stop I I could see how it would be
confusing very confusing you see what I
mean so when you for example if you're
if you're very sad if you're if you're
in a traumatic situation or if you're
desperate who' you call out
to God right which one I mean you call
out to the Father the Son the Holy
Spirit or all three at the same time I
would just say God exactly yeah and
that's what we would say there are vers
in the Quran that say that when the
people are in the sea and they're about
to be capsized and so on they will call
out to God in all earnestness and
sincerity but when they come back to the
shore then you'll you'll see them um
ascribing partners with God MH see God
doesn't want you to ascribe partners
with him it's in the first ten
commandments right God wants to just
worship him alone mhm you see that's
what Jews have said all over the time
that's what you know in the first 10
commandments you'll find in the Old
Testament Etc so that's the first thing
I'll leave it with you I mean this seems
to be the first question because that's
one of the major differences between
Islam and Christianity the idea of God
that is one of the major the second
major difference is the prophet hood of
prophet Muhammad so is he a true Prophet
or not that's the question because if
he's a true
Prophet then uh clearly what he's saying
comes from God if he's not a true
Prophet then it's not then it's just a
man-made text man the 7th Century etc
etc but if we we owe it to ourselves to
explore the issue so for example we
would find that the prophet Muhammad had
a pure track record no one considered
him to be a liar no one considered him
in his community to be a liar at all
they all knew him very well he came when
he was 40 years old after living a full
life amongst them and told them that he
was a
prophet and he didn't just say that
frivolously he Pro he provided
evidences so the kind of evidences that
we have as Muslims for example is number
one the preservation yes the fact that
the Quran does not have any
contradictions in it that's an important
thing the Theology of course of of Islam
but also there a range of other things
for example the predictions of Islam so
Islam makes a series of predictions
about the future about how life will be
in the future let me give you ones that
are pertinent to your to your
work there are predictions in Islam that
say that women are going to join the
workforce with men oh no way yeah in the
future there's a woman will join the
workforce with men this is one
prediction another thing you've spoken
about which is mentioned the prediction
of that Prophet is that there will be
will come a time where people will
engage in promiscuity sexual intercourse
outside of the marital structure to such
an extent where sexually transmitted
that there will be an advent of such
sexually transmitted diseases so
sexually STDs will come about as a
result of this um degenerative behavior
that people in the future are going to
do so I guess my question
cuz you know I'm a believer of people
are people and so it would be I would be
very shocked if at no point in history
there was like like didn't King David
have like 300 wives or something in the
Bible yeah yeah like people were like to
me that's not a Godlike I mean it might
be true I'm not trying to be like
disrespectful but it's like I wouldn't
put that
as a Godlike prediction sure one or two
of them wouldn't be but if I had 50 of
the same kind of precision and
sophistication what's the best one give
me like the uh I'll give you three or
four good ones okay so for example in
the Quran is mentioned in chapter 30: 1
to 4 that the Romans had been defeated
and remember we said that the Roman
Empire and the Persian Empire they had
been kind of going at it yeah there were
two major Empires even at the time of
the prophet
and that in 3 to nine years that they
will win and they will and they will win
in a nearby lowland okay now this
prediction has been M has materialized
now you're a volleyball player for
example yeah if I said I don't know
whatever team you play for right I say
look pearly's team is going to win and
they're going to win 5 nil and they're
going to win at this time in this place
yeah I mean that's a pretty good predic
I'm getting this from God if it if if
the opposite happens or if you don't win
or if there's a draw or if this whatever
it
is um then it completely discredits what
I'm saying so would the Christians come
in so if I said hey Christians there's
50 things that Prophet Muhammad said am
I allowed to say his name I don't know I
don't I don't know I know there's some
like yeah we believe that's in the Quran
though that so we believe the Quran
remember it's from god let's mention the
Quran and the Hadith okay yeah well so
if I said that to the Christians would
they say yes you're right all the
predictions were correct they couldn't
deny this one and I have actually
presented this to uh even the Christians
would agree with you they'd have to okay
on this issue I don't think there's any
controversy whatsoever because it just
happen and there is there's
corroborating evidence outside of the
Quran and Sunnah there's Roman primary
source historical information about this
okay do you know what I mean so that's
one thing there's there's a book that
was written by a friend of mine called
The Forbidden prophecies by Abu Zak his
name is Abu Zakaria and he lists a lot
of these predictions a lot of them a lot
of them is where Islam will spread what
countries it will spread to like Egypt
like for example Yemen and Jordan and uh
present day Palestine Etc a lot of the
countries that we know Islam has spread
to uh a lot of them have to do with the
economy economy for example one of them
is that that interest will overwhelm the
economic system so that you will not be
able to get away from it whatsoever and
all a lot of it is to do with the
infrastructure for for example one of
the famous one is that the barefooted
Arab the barefooted Arabs will ra will
compete to raise tall buildings MH we
know now the tallest building in the
world is in in Dubai inif right one the
third most tall building in the world is
Mecca it's the clock tower you know so
they're competing with each other now to
exactly that someone could say was a
self-fulfilling prophecy but it couldn't
be a self-fulfilling prophecy if the
economic um
situation wasn't there if they didn't
have money to do that you needed to have
a certain amount of GDP to do that so